Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Four, Episode Six: Danish foreign and security policy after the Cold War.
Let's start with a shift.
Even though Denmark, with its entry into NATO in 1949, gave up its traditional neutrality, Denmark kept a relatively low military profile until the end of the Cold War, around 1990.
Denmark did, however, take part in many of the UN's peacekeeping missions.
The task here was typically partly to help ensure that a ceasefire was observed, and partly to protect the civilian population.
Now the period of foreign policy activism after the Cold War, 1990 to 2022.
After the end of the Cold War, NATO's goals gradually changed.
NATO remained a defence alliance.
NATO is an international defence alliance, a forsvarsalliance, not a trade area and not a refugee cooperation.
But the goal also increasingly became to promote peace, democracy, human rights and the rule of law around the world.
In that connection it played a big role that NATO, after the end of the Cold War, has been clearly the world's strongest military and security-policy alliance.
NATO, led by the USA, was thus less worried about being attacked or ending up in armed conflict with other countries.
And Denmark developed, little by little, a so-called "activist foreign policy".
That meant that Denmark began to take part more actively in international conflicts that went beyond peacekeeping missions.
This was expressed in different ways.
In 1990 to 91, Iraq occupied its neighbour Kuwait.
On the basis of a UN decision, the USA led a military effort to liberate Kuwait.
Denmark sent a warship as a contribution to the international military force.
The ship did not take part in active combat, but had the task of enforcing the international community's trade blockade against Iraq.
In connection with the civil war in Yugoslavia in the beginning of the 1990s, Danish soldiers were sent out as part of the UN forces.
Here they were involved in direct combat with Serbian forces in Bosnia in 1994.
Also in Kosovo, which at that time was a province in Serbia, there was civil war at the end of the 1990s.
Here the Albanian population majority was subjected to abuses from the Serbian government.
After long negotiations without result, NATO intervened militarily in 1999.
Danish fighter planes took part in NATO's actions.
Next, the efforts after the terror attack on the USA in 2001.
A turning point for security policy in the NATO alliance, and Denmark among them, was the terror attack on the USA on the eleventh of September, 2001.
Here terrorists killed about 3,000 people by hijacking passenger planes and flying them into, among other things, the World Trade Center in New York.
After this terror attack, fighting terrorism became an important task for the alliance.
After the terror attack, NATO took a new step and decided to strengthen its ability to fight any threat against the populations, territories and military forces of the member countries.
This also applied to terror threats from terror groups.
Denmark has therefore since 2001 taken part in military missions around the world that have had a focus on these goals.
The terror organisation Al Qaeda, which was behind the attack on the USA on the eleventh of September, 2001, had its base in Afghanistan.
This gave occasion for forces, led by NATO and with a mandate from the UN, to invade the country in October 2001 and depose the Islamist Taliban government, which cooperated with Al Qaeda.
In 2002, a large majority in the Danish Folketing decided to send Danish soldiers to Afghanistan to take part in the war.
For 20 years, the Taliban fought a guerrilla war against the international forces and the new, Western-supported Afghan government.
The Danish soldiers were, among other things, stationed together with British troops in the southern Helmand province, which was one of the most unsettled in the country.
In total 44 Danish soldiers lost their lives during the fighting.
After 2014, the task of the Danish deployed soldiers was to train and support the Afghans so they themselves could take care of security in the country, and since then the Danish and other countries' soldiers have been withdrawn completely.
As the international forces left Afghanistan, the country's government and army collapsed.
In August 2021, the Taliban recaptured the capital Kabul and thereby power in the country.
The West, including Denmark, started a historically extensive evacuation of its own diplomats, military advisers, and of Afghans who had worked for the West, such as interpreters, during the war.
In 2003, the USA and a number of other countries fought a war against Iraq and the country's dictator Saddam Hussein.
The war was justified by Iraq not living up to its obligations on military disarmament, which had been imposed on it by the UN after the Gulf War in 1991.
In addition, the USA believed that Iraq had illegally developed weapons of mass destruction.
However, no such weapons of mass destruction were ever found.
This war was without a clear mandate from the UN, and it was not a NATO mission either.
The war was carried out by an alliance of countries led by the USA and with the support of, among others, the United Kingdom and Denmark.
Several NATO members, among them Germany, France and Norway, did not want to support the war.
In Denmark it was only a small majority in the Folketing that voted for Denmark's participation in the Iraq War.
Saddam Hussein was removed from power in 2003.
After that the focus shifted to rebuilding Iraq after the war, to creating better living conditions for the Iraqis through humanitarian efforts, and to creating democracy.
The Danish soldiers took part in this work together with soldiers from other countries.
This work has, however, been made difficult by the removal of Saddam Hussein setting off a flare-up of several conflicts in Iraq between the country's different ethnic and religious groups, including the Sunni Muslim minority, which Saddam Hussein came from, and the Shia Muslim majority, which now gained power.
At times the situation in Iraq has resembled civil war.
In total, eight Danish soldiers died in connection with the American-led intervention in Iraq.
And one more.
In 2011, an uprising broke out against Libya's dictator Muammar al-Gaddafi.
The uprising happened at the same time as uprisings in several neighbouring countries, for example Tunisia, Egypt and Syria, which became known as "the Arab Spring".
A united Folketing decided that Denmark could take part in a military intervention in Libya.
The intervention was, in accordance with a mandate from the UN, to protect the civilian population from abuses by Gaddafi.
Denmark provided aircraft for the operation and carried out several bombings of Gaddafi's army and military bases.
Subsequently Libya has been an extremely unstable country with weak governments, and where warring groups have been in something that is best described as a civil war.
Libya has also become the starting point for many African migrants who seek to Europe across the Mediterranean.
Here is your recap for Episode Six.
Denmark joined NATO in 1949 but kept a low military profile until around 1990, taking part in UN peacekeeping.
After the Cold War, Denmark developed an activist foreign policy.
In 1990 to 91, a Danish warship enforced the trade blockade against Iraq.
Throughout the Cold War, Denmark was not neutral and not allied with the Soviet Union in the Warsaw Pact: it was allied with the USA and the other Western countries through NATO.
Danish soldiers fought Serbian forces in Bosnia in 1994, and Danish fighter planes took part in NATO's action in Kosovo in 1999.
The terror attack on the USA on the eleventh of September, 2001, killed about 3,000 people.
Al Qaeda was based in Afghanistan; NATO-led forces invaded in October 2001, and the Folketing decided in 2002 to send soldiers.
44 Danish soldiers died in Afghanistan, and the Taliban retook Kabul in August 2021.
In 2003, Denmark took part in the Iraq War, without a clear UN mandate and not as a NATO mission, with only a small majority in the Folketing; eight Danish soldiers died.
In 2011, a united Folketing decided to take part in the intervention in Libya, with a UN mandate.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What is NATO?
Option A: An international free trade area.
Option B: An international defence alliance.
Option C: An international refugee cooperation.
[DA] Hvad er NATO?  A: Et internationalt frihandelsområde  |  B: En international forsvarsalliance  |  C: Et internationalt flygtningesamarbejde
The answer is B: An international defence alliance.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: En international forsvarsalliance
Question 2.
When did Denmark become a member of NATO?
Option A: 1949.
Option B: 1957.
Option C: 1973.
[DA] Hvornår blev Danmark medlem af NATO?  A: 1949  |  B: 1957  |  C: 1973
The answer is A: 1949.
It appeared in the May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 1949
Question 3.
What characterised Denmark's defence policy through most of the Cold War?
Option A: Denmark was allied with the USA through NATO.
Option B: Denmark was neutral.
Option C: Denmark was allied with the Soviet Union through the Warsaw Pact.
[DA] Hvad kendetegnede Danmarks forsvarspolitik gennem det meste af Den Kolde Krig?  A: Danmark var allieret med USA gennem NATO  |  B: Danmark var neutralt  |  C: Danmark var allieret med Sovjetunionen gennem Warszawa-pagten
The answer is A: Denmark was allied with the USA through NATO.
It appeared in the November 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Danmark var allieret med USA gennem NATO
Question 4.
When did the Cold War end?
Option A: Around 1950.
Option B: Around 1970.
Option C: Around 1990.
[DA] Hvornår ophørte Den Kolde Krig?  A: Omkring 1950  |  B: Omkring 1970  |  C: Omkring 1990
The answer is C: Around 1990.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Omkring 1990
Question 5.
Which country did Denmark send soldiers to following the terror attack on the USA on the eleventh of September 2001?
Option A: Mali.
Option B: Kosovo.
Option C: Afghanistan.
[DA] Hvilket land sendte Danmark soldater til på baggrund af terrorangrebet i USA den 11. september 2001?  A: Mali  |  B: Kosovo  |  C: Afghanistan
The answer is C: Afghanistan.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Afghanistan
Question 6.
Which country did Denmark send soldiers to in 2003, following an American-led invasion?
Option A: Syria.
Option B: Iraq.
Option C: Libya.
[DA] Hvilket land sendte Danmark soldater til i 2003 på baggrund af en amerikansk ledet invasion?  A: Syrien  |  B: Irak  |  C: Libyen
The answer is B: Iraq.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Irak
Question 7.
Did the Danish government at the time support the American-led invasion of Iraq in 2003?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Støttede den daværende danske regering den amerikansk ledede invasion af Irak i 2003 (Irak-krigen)?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
That's the end of this part.
Well done.